I don't know if it's a specific project for that, it's
not so far away
Anne hasn't been openly active as an evil organization since the battle with the hero
It means that it is repeating the best of yin and yang to improve the monster's performance.
So, in other words, what I'm focusing on at the moment is
expanding the scope of development and operation of the Phantom, but there are some parts
that feel like a bit of a butterfly when aiming for world domination.I
can propose a more effective plan.
Ocha
[music]
You're not trying to betray the daytime politics, aren't
you?
If you're not old enough, you can hire it,
because if you're a
hero, you'll have to fight children.
]
Then the next question, it's a
pretty strict association
, I think you're going to think it
's an exaggeration
.
tuan
[music]
ran
tan
me
[music]
Next time I'll definitely crush you
meaaaaaaa
[music]
which one was darker